Let's talk about Marjorie Taylor Greene.
In a world of lies,
conspiracies and divisive rhetor
it is sometimes a tough call
on which ones to give oxygen to
and which ones to ignore.
But this morning, a sitting U.S.
congresswoman suggests
that if she had been in charge
of the January
six attack on the Capitol,
the crowds would have been armed
and they would
have, quote, won the insurrectio
Speaking at an event hosted
by the New York
Young Republican Club,
Marjorie Taylor Greene said this
I come to Washington.
I swear it.
On January 3rd,
I get accused of giving
insurrection tours,
which I thought was hilarious
because I couldn't
even find a bathroom in the Capi
whose story
that is dangerous things happen.
The next thing you know,
I organized the whole thing alon
me, and I'm here
and I've got to tell yourself th
and I had organized
that we would have one
that's not to mention
an armed
staff.
See, that's a whole joke, isn't
They say the whole thing was pla
and I'm like, Are you kidding me
A bunch of conservative
Second Amendment supporters
went in the Capitol
without guns,
and they think that we organized
I don't think so.
Well, those are interesting comm
to say the least, considering
how she felt during the attack.
Greene message
White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
and I quote here,
Please tell the president to cal
This isn't the way to solve anyt
publicly, of course.
A different tune.
Just a week and a half later,
she pushed Meadows to stage a co
getting the military involved
so that Trump could stay in powe
Quote,
in our private chat with only me
several
are saying
The only way to save our republi
is for Trump to call for martial
spelled it incorrectly.
There,
she justified that request
by perpetuating the lie
that led to the violence at the
in the first place.
Writing They stole this election
We all know they will destroy
our country. Next. Caitlin
Walden.
Let's talk about more of this
with CNN senior political analys
and author of Wingnuts
John Avlon
and CNN
political commentator Errol Loui
who is a columnist for New York
and the host of You Decide Podca
one.
They did bring weapons to the Ca
on January six, correct? Yeah.
They're saying what
this congresswoman is saying
is that they were insufficiently
Right. And she was playing to th
But what she's basically saying
what we've been pointing out
without accountability
in these failed inspections
are just practice.
She's saying
that they would have succeeded
and they would have come armed
and that's a statement with real
If you're a member of Congress,
that's an endorsement of violent
sedition.
Like, make no mistake about it.
And it would have been illegal
to even
bring weapons
into the district,
as she no doubt knows it.
So it's it's
the kind of thing where
in the name of being cute
in front of the donors
or whatever group she was
she was addressing,
she could talk herself into a gr
I mean,
this is not stuff to take lightl
This is a country
that's on it's on the edge
in a lot of ways.
And if she really means this,
you know,
she should really repeat it unde
And I'd love to hear it.
It is problematic for
I would say for Republicans.
And it's problematic,
especially considering
where Kevin McCarthy is right no
trying to become the leader.
I mean, what does he do about th
And does this affect any of that
Well, she says, look,
the central problem for
American politics
and has been true for a number o
is what to do
about these kind of extremist
not just the statements,
but the actions that
undermining of institutions,
the undermining of elections
and faith in those elections.
So if if he can figure that out,
he'll have a very successful spe
I don't know that he can.
I don't know
that he can contain her
when people are going to
say crazy things,
you know, for money or for atten
or for some combination of both,
or in fact, because they believe
you know,
he's going to have to decide
who who gets the gavel,
who doesn't,
who gets the chairmanship,
how much he's willing
to fight with these people.
He's got the same
problem as the rest of us.
What do you do about the extremi
Yeah,
and it's it's more difficult
because he's trying to thread th
with majority support.
But, you know,
let's be real clear about this.
For all those Republicans who pr
you know,
this was just a bad tourism day.
Nothing really happened.
What Marjorie
Taylor Greene
just said the quiet part out
loud as she is want to do is
if we've been organizing it,
we would have been successful.
Successful in what?
Overturning an election,
our democracy and wide
because we would have been armed